Speaker 1: This is so funny.
Radical and repugnant, reactionary Congresswoman
Marjorie Taylor GREENE started complaining
about how student loan forgiveness, which
Joe Biden is now doing, is it's bad, it's
unfair that some people don't have to pay
back loans.
They took I mean, they took out a loan and
now they don't have to pay it back.
And it turns out that Marjorie Taylor GREENE
took out a nearly $200,000 loan.
That was the money made available to businesses
in the pandemic relief packages during the
Trump and Biden pandemic relief packages.
And it was forgiven.
She didn't have to pay it back.
Isn't that just the best?
Listen to this.
Here's Marjorie Taylor GREENE attacking the
Biden student loan debt relief.
Speaker 2: That's why they're the party where
you don't have to pay back loans.
That's why they're the party that is just
ripping our country apart.
And Joe Biden is wrong.
He can't break the law and just forgive everyone's
student loan debt.
It just doesn't work that way.
Speaker 1: Right.
The Democrats are the party where you don't
have to pay back loans.
And then we find out that the Marjorie Taylor
GREENE and Husband Business Taylor commercial
received a loan for $182,000 and they had
$183,000 forgiven.
Why is the amount forgiven more than the loan
amount?
Well, they also had accrued interest forgiven.
Isn't that nice?
That loan was reportedly for employee wages.
Of course, as with any of the there's so much
PPE fraud the IRS is investigating generally.
We don't have any reason to believe they're
specifically investigating the Marjorie Taylor
GREENE loan.
But how much of that money in theory for employee
wages actually went to Marjorie Taylor Greene's
employees?
That's a very, very good question.
And by the way, when she says it's the Democrats
who are the party of not paying back debts,
she supported Trump.
Trump, who often didn't pay debts, often didn't
pay people that he owed money to.
Now, I do want to mention there is some consistency
here.
I have to sort of concede it's pretty obvious
hypocrisy.
But there's one way you can interpret this
in which Marjorie Taylor GREENE is being consistent.
She's about compassion for businesses when
it comes to finances, but not for individuals.
And in that sense, it's coherent with her
philosophy to the extent we can call it a
philosophy that she's mad about individuals
not having to pay back loans, but she's fine
with businesses not having to pay them back,
even when it's all a complete sham.
What a lot of these businesses did with the
PGP Money.
But there it is.
Marjorie Taylor GREENE, a hypocrite.
Wednesday, August 31st, 6 p.m. Eastern.
We are doing a member's only town hall.
It will be broadcast live to everyone, but
only our existing members will be invited
to participate in this one and chat with me.
We will be streaming it on YouTube, Twitch
and Facebook.
But if you want to participate, you do it
via our discord at David Pakman dot com slash
discord.
And of course to be invited you must be a
member at join pacman dot com.
I'll remind you about it next week.
The David Pakman Show is
a viewer and listener supported program.
You can sign up at join Packman dot com.
You will of course get instant access to the
world famous bonus show.
Speaker 3: Oh, the bonus show where you want
to make money and everybody else that makes
money to fund themselves is bad.
Speaker 1: Thank you.
Alex Jones hates it.
We love it.
And you also get a commercial free audio and
video stream of the show every single day
when you sign up.
Join Pacman dot com.